[Musique]
bonsoir mardi 24 mars bienvenue dans
cette édition spéciale sur tv 78
émission consacrée comme chaque soir en
ces périodes de confinement à la
pandémie de coronavirus dans les
yvelines
mais d'abord cette information qui n'est
pas en lien direct avec le contexte
sanitaire actuelle nous avons appris
aujourd'hui est la disparition d'albert
uderzo 81 12 ans d'une crise cardiaque
père d'astérix avec son compère goscinny
dont les bandes dessinées se sont vendus
dans le monde à plus de 370 millions
d'exemplaires le dessinateur a résidé
dans les yvelines pendant plus de
quarante ans il avait une demeure à
l'est de la serpe d'or au tartre godrans
son village gaulois plus petites
communes d'île de france où il a été
également un temps maire adjoint uderzo
a d'ailleurs à dessiner son emblème
et c'est là qu'il possédait sa
collection fourni de voitures ferrari
est dominique habitant de ban baisse
souvient d'un homme simple et généreux
il avait rencontré uderzo à plusieurs
reprises dans sa jeunesse écouter
j'avais 16 ans était pontife sur la
commune de condé sur vègre c'est la
seule le petit garage qui avait on en
servez le carburant est en effet ils
avaient l'habitude de venir faire le
plein de toutes ces voitures américaines
c'est ferrari et tout ça dans cette
station là et c'était quelqu'un qui
avait le coeur dans la main généreux et
tout ça et on rigolait tout le temps
quand faisait le plein de ses voitures
américaines et tout ça c'était la seule
personne que j'ai gardé un souvenir qui
avait laissé un pourboire de 100 francs
très généreux voilà moi j'ai eu
l'occasion d'aller chez lui une deux
fois deux mémoires où il montrait ses
voitures et tout ça parce qu'il est il a
de même un avion de chasse de chez lui
voilà c'était vraiment quelqu'un de
généreux il vraiment quelqu'un qui ne se
prenait pas du tout la tête avec les ans
et voilà c'était quelqu'un comme tout le
monde
le point à présent sur la propagation du
coc u19 en ile de france d'après les
dernières données publiées hier lundi 14
heures par santé publique france 6201 ce
qui a été recensés dans la région + 9
128 cas donc en 24 heures entre dimanche
et lundi la pandémie continue de
s'installer dans la région
une vague de cas positifs et d'ailleurs
à relever à versailles trois adjointes
au maire et plusieurs fonctionnaires de
la ville ont contracté le coronavirus
aucune personne est hospitalisée pour le
moment précise le maire françois de
mazières
hasard de cette information d'après nos
confrères du parisien ces agents et lui
tenait tous des bureaux de vote comme
assesseur le soir du premier tour des
élections municipales dimanche 15 mars
et mai le lien est difficile à faire
pour l'heure et dans ce contexte de
confinement et de pandémie la cgt des
yvelines demande la fermeture de toutes
les activités professionnelles qui ne
relèvent pas des missions essentielles
dans un courrier transmis ce jour à la
préfecture des yvelines à l' agence
régionale de santé ou encore au medef 78
le syndicat relaie l'inquiétude remonté
par plusieurs salariés elle notamment
une situation en particulier celle de
l'ehpad du parc des dames à saint
germain en laye où il y aurait et 14
décès parmi les résidents et sept
salariés contaminés à ce jour écoutez à
ce propos la secrétaire départementale
de la cgt des yvelines interrogé par
nicolas kirillovitch la cgd demande
c'est que seules les activités
réellement essentiel vital continuer à
fonctionner avec bien sûr la protection
des salariés mais pour tout ce qui n'est
pas indispensable puisque la consigne
c'est qu'il faut rester chez soi pour
protéger au maximum bas il faut que les
entreprises y contribue également et
c'est pas forcément le cas partout avec
des mesures de protection qui ne sont
pas assurés y compris parfois dans des
services essentiels dans dans la santé
le social ou le médico social
nous sommes particulièrement inquiets
pour tout ce qui est de l'aide sociale à
l'enfance par exemple les foyers
d'hébergement et la situation dans les
maisons de retraite qui était déjà un
satisfaisant
il ya quelques mois et qui devient très
critique pour évoquer ce n'était pas de
saint-germain-en-laye vous fait vous
vous dites dans votre communiqué de
presse qu'il y a kylie à sept agents de
cet ehpad qui sont confinés puisque
contaminés du coc vie de 19 et qu'il y a
eu 14 décès récemment dans cet ehpad
est-ce que vous avez la preuve formelle
d'un lien entre entre la continuer
contamination des salariés et les décès
dans cet ehpad
c'est une situation qu'on a prise
seulement seulement hier et c'est
évidemment beaucoup plus compliqué de
communiquer surtout dans des services
comme ça où ils sont déjà en
sous-effectif
mais en tout cas on voit bien les
informations commencent à aider à
diffuser le fait qu'effectivement la
situation dans les maisons de retraite
les pas seulement en france devient
devient critique
on sait que les personnes âgées sont
fragiles elles ont en plus souvent
d'autres pathologies et le personnel
dans les ehpad la bad mask
donc pourquoi la force de ses mots plus
de matériel pour pour protéger les
salariés du coup les résidents par
conséquent bien sûr on peut on ne peut
pas accepter dans une société comme la
nôtre de se dire ben ils sont âgés tant
pis non bien sûr c'est pas assez pas
acceptable et on doit protéger les
salariés les résidents toutes les
personnes fragiles notamment dans des
structures d'hébergement et à propos de
ce cas particulier à saint germain en
laye le groupe korian gestionnaire de
l'ehpad n'a pour le moment apporté
aucune réponse à nos sollicitations
pendant le confinement les écoles ne
sont pas ouvertes bien sûr leur
fermeture a même été prononcée à partir
du 16 mars afin de maintenir le lien
entre professeurs et élèves l'éducation
nationale a organisé une continuité
pédagogique ressources numériques cours
via le cned classe virtuelle la rectrice
de l'académie de versailles en visite le
13 mars dernier dans les locaux de
l'inspection académique des yvelines à
guyancourt avait précisé le dispositif à
notre micro
elle passe par plusieurs éléments elle
passe par des des modalités de
l'enseignement à distance qui sont
prévues par le cned mais on a aussi
d'autres ressources qui passe par les
ent ou par des blogs d'enseignants et
puis cela passe par la possibilité
d'ouvrir des classes virtuelles une
classe virtuelle c'est un écran la
classe le professeur un tableau sur
lequel on peut écrire la possibilité de
lever la main de répondre et d'interagir
avec les élèves pour assurer ses classes
virtuelles dont parle la rectrice il
faut cependant être équipé les pôles de
développement web o'clock a décidé de
mettre à disposition sa technologie de
classe virtuelle pour les écoles
universités et organismes de formation
école labellisée campus du numérique par
saint quentin en yvelines au club forme
ses étudiants en télé présentiel par le
biais de salles de classe virtuelle elle
la demande pour les structures
intéressées et à adresser par mail pour
les professeurs aussi pas question
d'arrêter de donner des cours à leurs
élèves dans un quotidien qu'ils ont dû
réadapter en se servant des outils mis à
disposition par l'éducation nationale
mais aussi en s'occupant de leur propre
vie de famille mélanie poquet à échanger
justement avec un professeur des essarts
le roi et ses lunes pereira dos santos
vous êtes professeur de mathématiques
mais ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
un tout petit peu plus oui bonjour je
suis enseignante au collège les molières
nécessaire le roi et janssen cette année
à des élèves de 3e et 2,5
voilà alors depuis lundi vous est
confiné sur ordre de la présidence
quel est votre quotidien sont de très
longues journées de travail avec de
nombreuses heures passées derrière
l'écran d'ordinateur à vrai dire je suis
étonnée moi-même de la fatigue que ça
représente et du temps passé pour
préparer ces petites séquences de coin
en fait je réalise qu enseigner à
distance bassa s'improvise pas du tout
découpez les cours en petit diaporama
avec des commentaires explicatifs
préparer des exercices leur correction
mettre tout ça en ligne ça prend
énormément de temps
d'ailleurs j'ai dû revoir un petit peu
mes exigences à la baisse en terme de
contenu parce que je me suis rendu
compte en voyant ce que font mes enfants
que ce que je donnais c'était peut-être
un petit peu trop
donc voilà on improvise on tâtonne on
essaye de s'améliorer mais c'est vrai
que c'est beaucoup de travail et
beaucoup de temps passé est-ce que vos
élèves sont réceptifs sont présents
derrière leur écran d'ordinateur pour
suivre ces séquences
alors en fait moi j'ai choisi de ne pas
utiliser de logiciel qui ne respectent
pas les lois de protection des données
et qu'ils utiliseraient des fichiers
avec des numéros des lèvres des e-mails
delhelle donc j'utilise uniquement
pronote car un logiciel de cahiers de
textes classiques et puis le nt
l'environnement numérique de travail
donc je vais pas de contact direct avec
eux mais par contre je leur ai donné mon
email professionnelle et donc certains
d'entre eux m'ont envoyé des messages
avec par exemple des photos de leurs
copies ou bien des questions précises
sur le court
donc j'ai gardé le contact avec certains
d'entre eux mais pour d'autres banon
fait la communication est remplie
j'avais demandé en troisième un petit
travail à me rendre lundi il ya quand
même deux ou trois élèves qui n'ont pas
qu'ils n'ont pas rendu le travail donc
voilà j'arrête
on ignore les causes et c'est parce
qu'ils n'ont pas de l'ordinateur à la
maison ce qui est possible
ça vous inquiète un peu justement il
leur côté ya de l'inquiétude au c alors
évidemment il ya s'inquiète aussi parce
que ce sont les élèves les plus fragiles
qui risquent d'être pénalisés par ce
système d'enseignement à distance en
classe on a un échange continu elle avec
des questions même ne serait-ce que par
des échanges de regards on voit quels
sont les élèves qui sont perdus donc à
ce moment là on est attentif on leur
pose des questions on les interroge pour
essayer de comprendre ce qu'il va pas là
évidemment tout ça ça n'existe pas donc
moi ce qui m'inquiète c'est chez sur la
durée en fait merci beaucoup c'est une
pereira dos santos
je vous remercie et de l'autre côté des
ordinateurs les élèves ou les étudiants
qui continue de suivre les cours à
distance est notamment margot boissarie
elle est étudiante à l'estaca sur le
campus de saint quentin en yvelines est
depuis chez elle dans la région
bordelaise où elle est confinée elle
poursuit sa formation en aéronautique
écouter les étudiants qui restent
mobilisés et qui continue aussi de faire
vivre leur association c'est le cas on
va le voir avec margot boissarie bonjour
bonjour vous êtes étudiante en 3e année
aeronautica à l'estaca sur le campus de
saint quentin en yvelines vous est
également la présidente de l'association
étudiante
estac modélisme vous allez nous en
parlait tout à l'heure qui a dû
notamment annulé une course de drones
qui était prévu dans l'est dans les
prochains jours déjà
parlez nous de votre expérience
personnelle de confinement vous êtes
vous originaire de la région bordelaise
vous êtes retourné dans cette région
bordelaise pendant ce confinement
comment ça se passe pour vous mais
écoutez je continue à suivre mes cours
je
m'occupe comme je peux j'ai commandé des
puzzles je suis une maquette d'avion je
m'occupe du jardin les faire des courses
quand c'est nécessaire je sorte le moins
possible et voilà je regarde un peu la
télé j'arrive à m'en occuper ça va donc
on cherche à s'occuper pendant cette
semaine je me dis vous êtes vous à
l'estaca présidente également plus a
détruit être étudiante vous êtes
présidente d'une association étudiante
qui s'appelle estaca modélisme est ce
que vous continuez ce rôle à distance ce
rôle de président de l'association estac
à modélisme alors pour l'instant ce
début de confinement on s'occupe des
événements qui ont été annulés comme
vous l'avez dit précédemment on a dû
annuler d'autres courses annuelles de
drones donc c'est une comme ça s'appelle
l'estacade renard est donc cette année
c'était l'édition numéro 4 ça se passe
c'est une course de drones qui se passe
un parking souterrain de l'école tous
les ans est donc cette année celle de
l'espace et le 17 et 18 avril nous
avions créé une nouvelle course qui
était réservé aux étudiants donc au
s'occupe de recontacter tous les pilotes
qui s'est inscrit l'entreprise de
chronométrage que nous allions nous
contacter et donc on annule tout ça
alors alors comme étant une prochaine
édition l'année prochaine
aussi on avait une événement avec donc
avec les c'est l'association de
modélisme de laval car l'estac à deux
campus à la saint quentin en yvelines
on a vu une rencontre prévue la semaine
dernière sur deux jours on a dû
l'annuler on avait défait des commandes
de matériel et du coup on va sûrement la
reporter en septembre nokia l'on sait et
presque autant de travail pour organiser
que pour désorganiser pour annuler tout
ça c'est ça oui car on essaye de garder
des bons contacts avec les personnes que
nous avons contactés pour pouvoir
réitérer l'expérience l'année prochaine
donc ça c'est pour votre association
vous êtes aussi avant d'être président
d'une association étudiante je le disais
en 3e année aéronautique à l'estaca sur
le campus de saint quentin en yvelines
comment vous maintenez le lien avec vos
autres camarades est ce que vous
continuez de suivre malgré tout des
cours à distance
alors oui on a commencé ce matin à 8h30
j'avais cours de mode de propulsion donc
l'école a décidé d'utiliser la
plateforme microsoft ims pour nos cours
cela fonctionne très bien moi j'ai très
bien mais j'ai vu j'ai pu suivre
parfaitement mon cours ce matin après
les la semaine dernière on n'a pas du
tout court car l'équipe pédagogique a
tenu à nous offrir une des méthodes qui
ont été mises au point qui ont qui
fonctionne en fait ils ont voulu
vérifier si tout cela fonctionnait si
les profs étaient présents ils ont
adapté notre emploi du temps donc ils
ont travaillé à semaine dernière à tout
cela est donc cette année on peut
accéder
cette semaine on peut accéder à des
cours bien bien mise en place de plus
nous on a des projets en cours on doit
continuer pendant confinement car on a
des rendus de projets à faire donc on
communique par messenger avec nos
groupes de projets par visioconférence
sur 1007 sur messenger et ça fonctionne
très bien on utilise aussi teens quand
cela peut que ça peut quand ça peut se
faire
et on continue nos projets on a installé
aussi la wii l'école nous a mis à
disposition les dix ans pour les
logiciels qu'on doit utiliser nous en
misant pour mise à disposition de plein
de tutoriels pour la mise en place de
ces logiciels sur nos ordinateurs
donc on a compris un les cheveux qui
continuent de s'organiser malgré tout à
distance merci margot boissons russe
avec plaisir et bon courage à vous je
rappelle que vous êtes étudiante à
l'estaca et présidente de l'association
étudiante estaca modélisme
merci à vous pour les plus jeunes ce
sont les parents qui doivent organiser
leurs cours à domicile c'est le cas par
exemple pour wilfrid richy rédacteur en
chef de tv 78 qui est confiné chez lui
avec ses proches deuxième témoignage de
ma vie de confiner que nous vous
proposons mois le confinement et ben est
synonyme de garde d'enfants il faut
rester à la maison pour faire travailler
les enfants de 2 à 13 ans donc primaires
et puis collège la plupart des
enseignants fournissent des exercices
pour
non seulement travailler ce qui était en
cours actuellement en classe et puis
aussi revoir un peu les acquis aussi
bien français que les mathématiques
on utilise donc pour les faire
travailler les ressources qui sont
fournies par les enseignants les cours
du cned aussi et puis c'est un peu
forcément la débrouille on instaurait
aussi un rythme à la maison pour
maintenir des moments précis de travail
travail le matin activités plutôt manuel
l'après midi et puis bien sûr aussi
garder un rythme donc le coucher on
garde à peu près le même que celui de la
période de l'école pour pas trop
déboussolés les enfants qui ont toujours
forcément aussi à plein plein de
questions sur la situation actuelle
il faut pas les sur angoisses et non
plus il faut essayer de garder le
maximum de normalité
et puis aussi cette obligation chez nous
de rester à la maison puisque certaines
personnes font partie des personnes
dites à risque donc les contacts à
l'extérieur se font uniquement par par
téléphone par par visiocom comme la
actuellement et dans cette ambiance
inédite chacun joue le jeu en tout cas
plus de trois cent mille élèves des
yvelines sont concernés par ce
confinement tout comme leurs parents
vous l'avez vu qu'ils doivent s'assurer
de la réalisation des devoirs leurs
enfants écouter la présidente de la pub
de montigny le bretonneux fédération de
parents d'élèves les propos sont
recueillis par mélanie poker et manuel
afonso bonjour vous êtes la présidente
de l'apel montigny-le-bretonneux
secrétaire départemental sur les
yvelines déjà question en tant que mère
de famille vous même comment vous vivez
ce confinement avec vos enfants à la
maison
alors comment on vit le confinement ben
écoutez on a déjà eu à relever le
challenge et l'organisation
ce qui n'a pas été une mince affaire
parce qu'entre l'école à la maison le
télétravail
et puis même tout simplement apprendre
le réapprendre le vivre ensemble ça a
été une sacrée aventure là au bout d'une
semaine de confinement on peut vraiment
peut vraiment dire que ça y est c'est
bon on est sur les routes
ben non le tout c'est de faire en sorte
que que notre enfant ne soit ne le soit
pas trop trop en difficulté vis-à-vis de
ces exercices
et voilà que ne pas se tirer dans les
pattes à toute la journée
justement l'arrêter ça va annoncer une
continuité pédagogique à l'appétit santé
que cette continuité est présente
ah oui à ça et a aucun doute là dessus
on a vraiment des professeurs ultra
impliqués dans leurs missions au
quotidien on reçoit des plannings avec
des exercices avec avec des consignes
même si j'avoue que certaines méthodes
de travail aurait gagné à être un peu
plus informé auprès des parents mais en
soi on a vraiment une bonne continuité
les professeurs restent disponibles à
moindre question on a une adresse mail
on a on a de la possibilité de skype et
aussi des fois il m'est arrivé de skype
et avec la maîtresse de mes enfants mais
toujours on va on n'est pas abandonnée
on a eu du mal en tout cas pour ma part
et pour la part des personnes que j'ai
sondé dans les différentes associations
du territoire des yvelines
on a ressenti au début une forme de
difficultés dans le sens où on n'était
pas assez en forme et sur les méthodes
de travail qu'il faudrait appliquer je
pense par exemple aux collégiens qui on
a certains établissements qui applique
l'emploi du temps vraiment au jour le
jour
le professeur est derrière son
ordinateur au moment où de prendre en
charge de la classe on a d'autres
établissements où ça ne fonctionne pas
comme ça on a des difficultés à
retrouver les ressources aussi des fois
non par exemple je prends l'exemple de
pronote certains professeurs vont mettre
dans les devoirs à faire d'autres dans
les ressources et à la classe et des
fois il ya des petits loupés en termes
de devoirs qu'on devrait rendre et qui
sont un peu raté mais en règle générale
franchement moi je trouve qu'ils ont
fait un travail extraordinaire qui
aurait gagné à avoir un peu plus de
moyens
même si manuel afonso président de la
pub de montigny-le-bretonneux
merci
vous l'avez peut être constaté
pas de gaz est de saint quentin en
yvelines ce matin l'hebdomadaire gratuit
n'a pas pu paraître ce mardi le média
local est forcément impacté par le
contexte actuel écoutez le témoignage de
damien guille et rédacteur en chef de la
gazette de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
interrogé par mélanie poker bonjour
damien est rédacteur en chef de la
gazette de saint quentin en yvelines
mais déjà une question un peu personnel
comment est ce que vous vivez le camp
suite ment autant qu'il viennois mois
pour attendre ce jusque là star a donc
on peut continuer à faire des courses et
il travaille un peu chez soi ça va c'est
juste pour moi beaucoup moins de monde
nous pose habituellement ça c'est quand
même un métier où on va vers les autres
donc d'être chez soi ça doit changer pas
mal de cotisants alors ça change
totalement c'est clair que là on a cent
fois moins de personnes que j'ai quand
on travaille habituellement
là où un peu au début on est au début du
confinement donc ça va mais je pense que
les reportages rendement qu non
justement comment s'est adapté votre
rédaction
est-ce que vous pouvez décrire le
quotidien d'un journaliste à la maison
j'en pense tant que savoir qu'on a
suspendu depuis
depuis ce mardi 17 la publication de la
gazette de saint-quentin-en-yvelines et
nous on avait pris des mesures déjà
entre guillemets de mise en quarantaine
des la semaine précédant la paix par
exemple n'a finalement pas couvert mais
annonce des résultats des élections
municipales en mairie on a tout fait
depuis le bureau de plus chez nous et
puis donc là nous on travaille plus pour
la côte est de 2 50 ans new line
actuellement la location suspendu en
papier comme sur le web
c'est à dire que jusqu'à ce que le
confinement général soit annoncée au
travail et par téléphone par téléphone
beaucoup de vent beaucoup de l'actionner
réseaux sociaux surveille les boîtes
mail pressé de survie un petit peu tout
ce qui se passe de sur les réseaux
sociaux puis pas mal de téléphones sont
restés
alors quelle est la suite pour votre
journal comment les gens vont pouvoir
lire des articles de vos journalistes
alors pourquoi donc ces valeurs pour la
garder de saint quentin en yvelines et
la caisse et en yvelines
les deux publications ont été stoppés
mais pour les journalistes travaillent
pour le site web tiers 78 tous là on est
en temps réel en temps réel donc tous
les jours on publie des articles
d'actualité chaude aussi tenir les
événements en ce qui peut se passer
autour de chez eux donc on pense
évidemment presque tous les articles
sont liées aux navires y merci beaucoup
et damien blue voilà c'est la fin de
cette édition spéciale on se quitte sur
ces images le concert de manu dibango
donné à guyancourt lors de la fête des
associations
en 2011 le chanteur et saxophoniste est
décédé dans un hôpital français bien ce
mardi à 86 ans des suites du corona
virus celui qui a plus de 60 ans de
carrière à son actif et qui a collaboré
avec gainsbourg ou encore sting nous
avait accordée à l'époque une interwiew
lors de sa venue dans les yvelines merci
de votre fidélité et belle soirée sur tv
70 qui connaît des saltimbanques qui
joue aussi bien pour 10 % que pour mille
pour sa remise l'essentiel c'est de
jouer de participer dès que les gens
pètent un musicien doit jouer tout le
temps peu importe les circonstances dans
quelles motivations derrière
[Musique]
non